.
Ça aura pris deux jours pour
parcourir 250 km. Les évacués
sont épuisés, mais sains et
saufs. Après untétététététététét
l'aide dont ils ont besoin
dans ce centre d'accueil.
Certains acceptent de raconter
un peu de , , , , , , , , , , ,s
jamais voir le soleil" dit-il."i
souterrain." Il ajoute qu'il
ne mangeait que du gruau etrtrt.
Le pire, c'était
les bombardements qui
étaient incessants.
ils larguaient des bombes
s-s-s-s-s-munitions avec
des parachutes.
Elles explosaient au bout
beaucoup d'éclats pour faireplp"
Tous resteront marqués
par ces jours passés entreanana,
sans électricité et sans
chauffage. Seulement
une centaine d'entre eux ont
pu s'extraire, cet
l'immense complexe. Beaucoup
d'autres, on ignn,n,n,n,n,n,
sont encore terrés dans
les dédales so
OSNAT LUBRANI, coordinatrice
humani., Nat, , , , , , Ukraine
- Peut-être parce qu'ils avaient
trop peur.èèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèès
sommes arrivés, tous les
sont arrivés ici, sains et saufs
à Zaporijiia... sans auoboboboba
donner le courage au
de sortir.
- "Je vous en suppliimplore ceta
encore 42 personneenenenenenent
avec nous dans l'abri. 1 1 1 1 7
ans. Il fautdedededededede là
parce que les bombardementssssss
des civiououououououous
les militaires qui continuentèèa
est en.......uxuxuxuxuxuxux luit
sauvés, dit-il, j'espère qu'il
sera prudent." En attendant
un peu, reprendre leur souffle.s
jouets et retrouvent leurs
sourires.etetetetetetetetetetetn
pu quitter Marioupol. De chezle.
"De notre balcon, on a vu cequqn
cendres." Et elles repartent
avec tout ce qu'elles possèdent
maintenant, quelques sacs,
mais au moins elles sont
ensemble et encore en vie.
Céline Galipeau,
Radio-Canada, Zaporij